your brothers and sisters in the slum
nap from Norway are establishing a
Masjid a dawa Center this Center this
Masjid this educational institution will
act like a beacon of light calling the
Muslims in Norway back to the essence of
Islam so give generously and Allah will
give you even
ask a question and both of you this is a
question to both of you is there an
ultimate purpose of life
yeah sure what is it what we're doing
here which is what
hopefully trying to make peace
is that enough
we'll see yeah because if it's better
than the alternative what's the
alternative hell
[Music]
okay which we're toying with I don't
mean us well us too that's for sure but
you know things are things are shaky at
the moment on many fronts and we have
this opportunity in front of us all of
us
to have a very abundant world right
where everyone has enough and maybe more
than enough and we're we're shaky about
that we're not sure that that's
acceptable and we're not sure everybody
should have it we're not sure everybody
deserves it and even ourselves and
and we're retreating into our Corners in
some real sense and we're not addressing
the elephants under the carpet and you
can't do that like the things we're
discussing contentiously now you know
they make for rough conversations but
they make for a lot rougher streets if
you don't talk them out and you have to
do that a spirit of ignorance you know
like I was hoping to come here today and
well unless and I talk a lot there's my
flaw you know but
I don't know how to feel the Right Way
Forward I think part of it is well first
of all to find commonalities we believe
in in the fundamental necessity of a
uniting book across the Jewish Christian
and Muslim faiths that's not nothing
like that's a strange thing to insist
upon and yet we all seem to agree we
believe in a higher and purposeful Unity
the necessity of that and then also in
the necessity of putting that Above All
Else and we also agree that we're not
very good at that but that's the hardest
one to get is that even if you do
claim in some sense to worship
the highest
in this monotheistic sense that doesn't
mean you're very good at it and that's a
hard pill to swallow especially when
you're trying to also be a courageous
Knight of your faith let's say it's hard
to be
properly humble in the face of the
Divine but that might be in some sense
the proper command I mean the fact that
Islam means submission is a reflection
of that in some sense right just
remember who's God here and who isn't
and so and that's a very hard thing to
keep in mind so when I listen to you you
disagreeable character I'm trying to
separate out the wheat from the chaff
you know because there's no doubt I have
many things to learn as I learn to some
degree honestly I appreciate this part
of like you know I learned from from
your humility honestly the way you come
across and once again I do appreciate
both of you coming here you know and I
appreciate the security is all that what
you've said that's good I deserve the
accountability just like he does I don't
want to be a person who you know who
doesn't count this out who dishes
out well can't get it himself I deserve
it what I wanted to say is this to both
of you I want to do a full experiment
yeah and so imagine you're going to
sleep I don't know where you guys are
staying now what hotel you're staying
you're watching my videos you know me
with the masks and stuff like that
before you go to sleep subscribe on the
channel whatever you do yeah and now
you're after you've you know put the
dislike and done your negative comments
which I deleted already and put it in
the trash
which is what you do is always tweets
and you know we can talk about that
later but after that's all happened and
you've gone to sleep you both will go to
sleep now right you wake up and you find
yourselves on a ship
on a ship yeah
and people are eating food people are
drinking people are just and that so
this thing's happening
now what would be the first questions
that you would ask
to people around you
would you ask things like how did I get
here where are we going is that are
these it does seem like the first yeah
those are good questions to ask in
general where are they how did we get
here and this is where are we going
beautiful that's what I wanted to
actually get to because this is what
Heidegger you know Martin Heidegger he's
a controversial freaking is all right
okay but he described us as the
thrownness of Life yeah because we're
chucked into life we're thrown into life
right so the fact now that we're in this
world
these questions that we'll be asking if
we were on a ship and were just chucked
on a ship well the same very questions
like you said you know that we would be
asking everyone as well in this world
where did we come from where are we
going I think if we can't get these two
questions right
nihilism will persist
you're a nihilistic expert you've spoken
a lot about nihilism I think if we can't
get those counter knives I'm not an
eyelid my if you want ask my what I
think my purpose the purpose is yes is
to be United with God okay beautiful
yeah beautiful okay so from the Islamic
perspective it's this right
first of all ask these three questions
whether I come from where am I going
what am I doing here what is the purpose
of life
and the answer is we came from
a Creator okay
so we can't we can we can approach this
in whatever argument you like I'm doing
PhD in contingency argument you can do
anything you want you can do it for
example through the the fact that the
universe is regular and stable and
uniform and possesses life what's the
best explanation for that is it
knowledge or not knowledge so you say
it's knowledge right or if we say it's a
creative capacity of some sort we came
from this creative capacity we came from
this knowledge Force right so that's the
first thing we'll say we came from this
Force this higher power where are we
going we're going back to the higher
power right and we're going back to the
higher power with our Deeds which we
have to be responsible for which is
exactly it's a Hallmark of what you
stand for and that's I believe genuinely
that's why you're asking why are so many
people listening to you
because we reject the original sin would
you respect original sin says that one
man yeah gave us gave us a sin the other
man took it away basically I mean we're
Fallen creatures and then Jesus You've
Got to Believe In the solo feeder you
believe in whatever you you know I'm
Orthodox so I don't believe that oh fair
enough okay I don't believe in original
sin the way you described it that's fine
but fine no no Norwich he's an orthodox
yeah yeah okay fine but the the issue is
that this I didn't say I believe didn't
either I just said that these the
concept of original sin is an expression
of this problem that we're describing
which is that we're all burdened with
something approximating while the
thrownness and this ambivalent
relationship we have with the atrocity
of history and but and that's worse
because if you study the atrocity of
history with any degree of seriousness
you have to take account of the fact
that people like you did it and you
might think well I wouldn't do it it's
like yeah I get you I wouldn't be so
sure about that for sure I mean you know
you were talking about the kind of you
you were talking about the suffering and
what obviously one of the major
sufferings is the Holocaust I was
reading the book the meaning for Life
Victor Frank I'm sure you're aware of it
where he then produced logo therapy and
all these kind of things and it goes
back to what Nietzsche said you know if
you have a why almost any how is
possible you know bearable yeah if you
have a why almost any house possible so
it goes back to everything goes back to
purpose logo therapy yeah just if you
have a purpose then everything is
possible that's why I think that you can
do the best as a human species yeah in
The Human Condition if your purpose is
Transcendental it's higher than the
physical the material and for us the
purpose is mentioned in chapter 51 verse
19 of the Quran which is
we have not created human beings and gin
except for that they may worship me what
is worship it's the epitome the higher
point of submission is the epitome of
love as well
Jonathan has an interesting take on that
too that has to do with celebration
which I think is psychologically
appropriate do you want to I don't want
to put you on the spot but but it's it's
in it it's something I've been
struggling to understand more I've
attended some Orthodox ceremonies with
Jonathan and also on my own and and he's
he's very uh perspicacious when it comes
to describing the role of both worship
and ritual and so there's an element
anyways I'll let you continue with that
no I agree I agree that worship is also
the manner in which we bind together
right and so without something we
celebrate together then we then we don't
and so we have different levels of what
we celebrate you know we can celebrate
in our families and the things that bind
us but ultimately that has to reach the
all the way up into something which is
beyond I think that's actually very
powerful you know and in fact the first
very first lines of the Quran is
alhamdulillah which is all praise and
thanks belong to God lord of the worlds
all praise in all thanks and this is a
kind of Celebration